it happened earlier this morning we're
told at around 9
40 a.m in the morning it was on a
training mission according to the 48th
fighter wing which is its uh home
squadron based at rf lakenheath
in suffolk which is a u.s air force base
it
is an f-15c eagle the
f-15c the c variant means it's a single
seater so would have had
uh just the one pilot on board it was on
uh what lady describes as a routine
training mission and the sort of things
that it could have been doing
uh potentially is air-to-air combat
drills because it is an air-to-air
fighter rather than
a bomber and the coast guard her
majesty's coast guard not the military
are are coordinating the response they
have this statement that they have
released within the last hour
they say hm coast guard is coordinating
response after
reports were received of an aeroplane
going down into the sea
74 nautical miles of flamborough head
the hm coast guard helicopter from
humberside
has been sent along with bridlington and
scarborough r
li lifeboats it continues following a
mayday broadcast by hm coast guard
other vessels nearby are heading to the
area it's believed the aircraft had one
person on board we have no further
information at the time so as you say a
major operation
taking place to try and find where that
aircraft that u.s
jet has come down off the northeast
coast in the north sea